عاد الملياردير جاك كاما إلى
البر الرئيسي للصين لأول مرة منذ
أكثر من عام ، زار مؤسس Alibaba
مدرسة تمولها الشركة
تحدث عن كيفية تأثير التغييرات في التكنولوجيا على
التعليم ، بدلاً من ذلك
تأتي زيارته في الوقت الذي يحاول فيه المسؤولون إحياء
الثقة في الأعمال بعد الوباء
و  القمع التنظيمي ،
تقرير رئيس مكتب CNN في بكين ، ستيفن يونغ ينضم
إلينا الآن ستيفن.ظهور نادر جدًا لجاك
ما ، فاجأتك
أنك تعلم لاحقًا أن الأمر كله شرس وجيد لدرجة
أننا وجدنا أخيرًا لمحة عن جاك
ما في بلده الأصلي الذي بدا أنه
كذلك  مرتاحًا جدًا كما تعلم في
سترة بيضاء عندما تحدث مدرس سابق
عن أحد موضوعاته المفضلة ،
كان ظهوره يجذب الكثير من
الاهتمام لأن اختفائه من
الصين بالطبع كان غالبًا ما يُعتبر
نقطة تحول في سياسة هذه القيادة
وموقفها تجاه
القطاع الخاص تذكر  بدأ كل شيء عندما
ألقى خطابًا في نوفمبر 2020
ينتقد بشدة المنظمين الماليين في البلاد
بعد فترة وجيزة رأينا أن
الاكتتاب العام الأولي المتوقع لإحدى
شركاته يتم سحبه ، ثم
تم التحقيق مع شركته في النهاية
مقابل غرامة قياسية بلغت 2.8
مليار دولار  وكل ذلك
يتزامن مع حملة واسعة النطاق
من قبل الحكومة على
القطاع الخاص بأكمله ليس فقط على التكنولوجيا
ولكن أيضًا على التعليم الخاص
والعقارات وفي بعض الأحيان
القضاء على مليارات الدولارات من
القيمة السوقية لبعض هذه الشركات  بين عشية
وضحاها طوال الليل عندما كان هناك
هذا البقاء الإعلامي حملة من
العداء تجاه ما يسمى
العواصم الشريرة والرأسماليين ، وهذا
بالطبع تفاقم بسبب
سياسة الحكومة وعدم التراجع عن سياسة السرية الصفرية على مدى
السنوات القليلة الماضية أه السنوات القليلة الماضية
تدمر هذه الاقتصادات حقًا